this autumn's scottish national party
conference is likely to be dominated by
a renewed push for a vote on
independence for scotland
well it would be easy to forget that for
nearly 15 years the snp has actually led
scotland's government
they're responsible for tackling covid
and they should be preparing to host the
historic cop 26 climate conference in
glasgow in just a few weeks time so
joining me now from glasgow is the
leader of the snp and first minister
nicolas sturgeon good morning first
minister
good morning
now in the programme
for government you delivered to the
scottish parliament this week which i
suppose for our international viewers
might best be described as
a queen's speech for scotland
you are clear that kovid's your number
one priority um numbers are spiking is
scotland in danger of a further lockdown
er no not at the moment i think any
responsible leader in the face of this
virus has to keep options open and be
careful not to rule anything out
we have seen a spiking case over the
past few weeks if you go back over the
summer we spiked above uk levels at the
start of july we then come down to some
of the lowest levels in the uk and as
our schools went back we saw cases
increase again we think we're seeing
that spikes start to level off and
stabilize the rate of increase has
slowed down it's what we're saying to
people right now is that in order to
drive infections down further which we
really need to do it's vital to comply
with all of the basic mitigations that
we still have in place in scotland for
example it's still a legal requirement
in certain settings to wear face
coverings
we're encouraging continued good hand
hygiene good ventilation um and of
course although it's not the law anymore
asking people to think about distance
from people in other households and
thinking about their overall number of
contacts so good sensible at compliance
with mitigations is what we think is
appropriate right now we also this week
got approval from the scottish
parliament for a very targeted and
limited system of vaccine certification
which we think can help us
reduce transmission in some higher risk
settings so at the moment that's our
message we're going into as everybody
across the uk is a very challenging
and difficult winter periods so it's
really important that we keep
a very close eye on what is happening
and lastly the overarching message to
anybody who hasn't yet done so and who
is eligible is to get vaccinated the
vaccines continue to be the single most
important thing any of us can do to keep
ourselves safer and to keep those around
us safer you are very clear um about
vaccine certification what uh is
popularly called the vaccine passport
but
some people including experts like steve
reichert the behavioral science
professor in scotland
say that
you should be concerned that the
introduction of certification actually
could put off some of the people that
you've just said you want to uh
take the vaccine
is that not a concern to you
steve reicher who's actually um on the
scottish government's advisory body uh
although he's entirely independent of
course
actually in a a very long and very
helpful twitter thread during the week
gave a very balanced account uh set out
the benefits of vaccine certification
set out and that uh it goes to the point
you're making here the the things we've
got to guard against if it is to work as
intended and also quite frankly set out
some of the downsides i think in the
face of the situation
people can take on balanced views i
think as part of a package of measures
it has a part to play what i was going
to say is firstly anybody who thinks
there is one single magic wand solution
to this virus probably hasn't learned
enough over the past 18 months and and
secondly of course any measure we take
has upsides and it has downsides i mean
if you take lockdown for example very
very effective at
halting or you know significantly
constraining transmission of the virus
but came with enormous costs in terms of
the economy and our overall well-being
as a society so nothing is
straightforward here this is a very
limited scheme it's very similar to what
has been proposed for england as well
and it has a part to play does it will
it uh reduce the the likelihood of
people who are not yet vaccinated to
come forward i don't think there's any
evidence of that if you look at
countries like france that's perhaps the
best example we we actually see the
opposite effect so the message is to
everybody who hasn't yet come forward to
take up the vaccine offer please do so
because it protects you and it protects
everybody it doesn't eradicate the risk
of transmission but it reduces the risk
of transmission and crucially it
significantly reduces your risk of
becoming seriously ill if you contract
covert
another big headline from your speech
this week was your proposal for a
national care service in scotland
which would cover all types of needs
including disabled disability and so on
um
are you envisioning that there would be
a spending cap in the way that the prime
minister has proposed for england wales
i think to ask me to address that
question trevor with the greatest
respect there has to first be an
understanding of the completely
different approach we already have in
scotland to the funding of social care
so it's not quite as simple as saying
are we going to replicate what is
happening in england so for example that
wasn't what i was saying
i simply just asked the question
but but for me to answer that question
and with a yes or no would belie the the
differences and i'm just not prepared to
do it um so for example what we have in
scotland that doesn't exist in england
is free personal and nursing care so
that means for anybody who needs social
care right now the state already meets a
much higher proportion of the cost of
that
your personal care needs or if you need
specialist nursing care that is met as
well so the funding landscape is
completely different and the the
arguments for a funding cap south of the
border are not really the same in
scotland now is the overall funding of
social care still a key consideration as
we move forward to national care service
absolutely alongside that commitment to
a new national care service we have a
commitment in scotland to increase
funding for social care over this
parliamentary term by 25
that in a scottish context is equivalent
to about 800
million pounds the national care service
is effectively and i'm going to
oversimplify here obviously but it's
effectively about making sure that we
have consistent and consistently high
standards of care across the country
that there's less variation at much
greater consistency and it is also about
enabling a move to supporting a
workforce
so that that workforce is better
rewarded at the national care service
envisages for example national pay
bargaining and a national wage for
social care workers because one of the
the issues not the only one but one of
the many issues in social care is the
under valuing of those who work in it
and there's a bigger issue there partly
because it's a predominantly female
workforce so we our starting point in
scotland is just so radically and
fundamentally different in england that
i would just guard against lifting what
is being proposed for england whether
you agree with that or not and trying to
transplant it into the scottish context
one thing that is that is
clearly
true about scotland is that right now
most of the care provision
is in the hand or it's controlled to a
large extent by local authorities and
scottish local authorities kosland
indeed the
city council in in glasgow where you
have your own constituency
have said that they are uneasy
about what they see as a centralization
what you've just called consistency but
essentially you are going to take
the
control of care service away from local
authorities in scotland and centralize
it
so you know to be frank this is one of
the key debates at the heart of this
reform and i suspect in scotland as we
move from uh what we've been doing over
the past few months which is consulting
into what we are about to do which is
religiously this is going to be one of
the tensions and one of the issues that
we need to resolve and you find this
often running through policy discussions
about this one person's consistency
which is what i've just said because
often
the complaints and the concerns that are
raised about social care is that lack of
consistency but one person's greater
consistency and less variability is
another person's centralization so we've
got to make sure we get the balance of
that right and of course we'll listen
very carefully to local authorities who
have expressed concerns about that you
know when you're trying to make a big
fundamental change here you know when
the country came out of the second world
war the national health service was
created we're trying to create a
national care service out of the trauma
of covid you know you can't make big
reforms like that without controversial
and difficult uh issues to try to
resolve but this isn't really a matter
of balance is it at the moment
social care is largely run by the local
authority board you want to take them
into i think they're going to be called
community health and
social care board which will be under
the control and funded by the scottish
government and i'm not making a a value
judgment about that but that is a change
that you want to make
well look we already have joint
integration boards across different
parts of scotland funding for social
care
comes initially from the scottish
government flows through councils in
terms of the provision uh we have a
mixed provision of uh state uh through
local authorities voluntary sector and
private private care homes for example
are a big part of our provision so i
guess i'm not trying to shy away from
this the point i'm making is that if you
if you take your starting point which is
a you know i said earlier on the
starting points in scotland are
different to elsewhere in the uk but
perhaps one point of consistency is that
the current arrangements around social
care is not are not as good as they can
be or as good as they should be so if
you accept that
and say we want to reform to make it
better you're going to have these
debates but let's have them and out of
those debates let's get a care system uh
that is fit for purpose learns the
lessons of the pandemic and is something
that in years to come we can look back
on with some pride as a good thing that
happened out of this covert crisis uh
there'll be difficult issues in this for
all governments across the uk but i
think it's time to face up to them
you said in your speech that you want to
have a further independence referendum
by 2023 covid permitting can we just
deal with the narrow question
of timing and covid what what does that
actually mean what level of infection or
hospitalization would make a referendum
impossible given that you've just had
elections in scotland in the middle of a
lockdown
well we just had elections and of course
and just before i i i
so that i don't miss this point the sap
won that election on a commitment to an
independence referendum with a historic
share of the voter constituency share of
the vote was higher than any party has
achieved in the entire lifetime of the
scottish parliament so it's probably a
point
of context that might be important for
our discussion okay
what would stop you having the
referendum
what what about covert would stop you
having a referendum
if you can let me i'm going to try and
address your question that it's uh
and i'll try to do it as fully as
possible you've made the comparison with
the election this is not just about
safety of polling stations it's about
making sure that as the country faces a
big important decision about its future
it's able to focus on that properly and
that it doesn't have looming over that a
covert crisis so right now you started
this interview rightly
about talking about the recent spike in
cases in scotland putting enormous
pressure on our national health service
leading me as the first minister to
continue to advise people to take great
care about their interactions i don't
think that kind of situation it would be
the best backdrop to the country
considering and making a decision on its
future i'm not going to set a precise
level of infections but you would want
to see the the covert situation
under control the pressure on our
national health service significantly
lower than it is right now a sense that
we weren't still in the acute phase of
this crisis but also crucially and i
think this is
a sort crucial
overall environment in the country where
people are not in their day-to-day lives
being asked to
even if not comply with legal
restrictions still limit or restrict
their own day-to-day behavior ultimately
of course as with many things in the
life of governments it will be a matter
of judgment and it's important that i
get that judgment right because i'm very
very serious and have been for 18 months
when i say
the biggest responsibility the most
serious responsibility on my shoulders
is steering the country through the
biggest health crisis in a century
first minister you know me well enough
to know that this is not the sort of
thing that would cross my mind but there
are some
nasty cynical people who would say that
the judgment you really want to make
is when will it be more likely that you
get the answer yes from a referendum
because right now the polls don't tell
you yes we want a referendum or indeed
if there were one that you would
definitely win and that really when you
say
code committing permitting what you
really mean is when it's politically
advantageous to me nicholas sturgeon
i think it's right for the country i'm
not going to sit here as as a politician
and say that in any decision i mean we
have fixed term parliaments in scotland
so it doesn't arise and for the time
being there are fixed ten parliaments in
the uk but when that wasn't the case
prime ministers of course used to make
judgments on when they would call a
general election based on when they
think they could best when any
politician is going to factor those kind
of judgments into those decisions and
i'm not going to sit here and pretend
otherwise of course some polls right now
do suggest that yes we'd win others
suggest that yes is slightly behind i i
i'm very confident that when this
question is next put people in scotland
will vote yes and one of those reasons
is that we have seen that all of the
things that were said to scotland by the
no campaign in the referendum in 2014
not least that being independent would
see us lose our european union
membership have turned out to be false
so i'm confident about that but my
primary uh consideration and the two are
not completely divorced from each other
my primary consideration is to do what's
right for the country when is it right i
think it's right that the country gets
to choose its future there are big
decisions that are falling to be made by
governments everywhere as we emerge from
this pandemic who do we want taking
these decisions democratically elected
governments here in scotland guided by
the values of the scottish people or
governments like boris johnson's in
westminster that we don't vote for so
that's the choice and we should make get
to make that choice when the time is
right for the country to do so
well let's talk about the values of
scottish people and what a an
independent scottish government would
look like um
i've seen the the video that
your parties put out
ahead of the cop 26 conference
proclaiming that scotland is ready for
net zero does that
mean closing down oil production in due
course
we're in a transition away from fossil
fuels so oil and gas production is not
going to last forever the question is
the pace at which we do that i think
we've got to see that pace accelerate i
think there are big questions over
whether we should continue with new
exploration uh in the north sea um and
the other question is how just is that
transition because what we don't want to
do is repeat the mistakes of at the the
deindustrialization that was underway
and that we had the legacy of when i was
growing up where individuals and
communities were just thrown onto
the scrap heap so it's about the pace
and the justice of that transition we
are already in that transition and we've
got to make sure that it happens at a
pace that has is consistent with our net
zero ambitions we have a target in
scotland to reach net zero by 20 45 but
actually we've got an even more
stretching target which is a 75
reduction in emissions by 2030. so there
are big big challenges for scotland here
but there are big challenges
for countries across the world glasgow
is about to host cop and this is
possibly the last chance the world has
to
do what is required to meet the paris
agreement of limiting temperature rises
to 1.5 degrees and we've got to get a
glasgow agreement that allows this
generation of leaders to look the next
generation in the eye
you just made a very important point
which is that
uh you've got to judge the pace but what
you don't want to do
is to create more production now does
that mean that you have decided
that the campbell oil field uh which i
think is east of the shetlands which
is has where there's uh oil companies
have applied for a license to drill but
you've decided that you
propose that you oppose the exploitation
of that field
so again let me address this and i've
set out my position clearly firstly can
i just factually connect
your introduction to that question
the developers of campbell have a
license they've had that license for i
think 20 years what they need to now do
is get permission to start
exploration and production so the
license is there which is part of the
the complication of forgiveness
against bringing oil ashore
i think that there has to now be a
process of reassessing that now what i
was going to say is it's not my decision
it's a reserved matter i've asked the
prime minister
not to simply go ahead and grant the
permission
to go ahead with production as a matter
of course that the license should be
reassessed against the same kind of
climate requirements as new licenses are
going to be assessed now there are
issues here that have to be considered
the pace of the move away from fossil
fuels
but in a way that a doesn't throw people
on the scrap heap but doesn't
inadvertently reduce that sorry increase
our reliance on imported oil and gas so
you're asking me to you're about to ask
me to simplify this
your green partners in government are
pretty clear they think you shouldn't
and i'm asking you if you'd had your
brothers would you not have i would that
oilfield exploited
i i would i wouldn't give the go-ahead
without a fundamental reassessment of
the license and that reassessment the
license exists so you have to do that
reassessment so i wouldn't give the
go-ahead without that reassessment to
enable that to be
done against the requirements of climate
change so that there is that rigorous
assessment of whether going ahead with
new exploration which i think many
people and increasing numbers of people
question whether that is consistent with
our climate change targets so that
assessment in my view should happen
let me just
quickly take you to a couple of um
rather controversial issues i think that
your government's um addressed um you've
issued guidance on racism to schools
which advises teachers to take a test to
measure their white privilege um have
you taken that test first minister
um i i sorry i haven't i'm happy to do
so um
but you know if you want to
give me more uh detail of that i will
certainly consider it but i'm not
entirely off the top of my head sure
what you're you're referring to well it
it it is a test which says uh
because of who you are and how you're
born uh you have privilege in your case
uh which i in my case do not have and
the advice that your department of
education has given is that schools
should give the teachers should take
this test to demonstrate that they
because they're white have this
advantage and i think it'd be rather
good i mean um why don't we do a deal
that the scottish cabinet the scottish
government cabinet takes the white
privilege test and one of you you or
you're one of your colleagues comes back
on and tells us what the results are
look i'm happy to to i think these
things are really important i don't have
the particular guidance in front of me
i'm not trying to to dodge your question
i did an interview with uh one of your
competitor channels on friday about many
of these issues and and as we consider
all of these issues people like me you
know white people have to constantly
remind ourselves that we have privileges
that the others don't have so i'm
perfectly happy to go away look at the
particular guidance and if there are
things that my cabinet should do to make
sure that what we're asking others to do
the things we're prepared to do
ourselves i'm happy to do that that's a
date very last very simple
straightforward question
a lot of work
on the gender uh reassignment issue
do you agree with the most famous
scottish based writer jk rowling
that
there is a biological basis to sex and
that you for example are
a woman
not a person with a womb but a woman
i am a woman and yes i do think there is
a a biological aspect to sex i'm not
going to simplify this by sort of saying
do i agree or disagree with jk rowling
there's many things i agree with her on
i'm sure on some of the nuances of this
we might take a different opinion but
let me you know address directly the
issue of the gender recognition reform
bill something that's happened already
in many other countries ireland included
this is about making it easier for trans
people we can go through this process
already but it's about making it less
degrading and traumatic for trans people
to legally change gender it does not in
any way shape or form remove the legal
protections that women have and that's
important to me as a feminist but trans
people are amongst the most stigmatized
minorities in our society and we should
try to reduce that if we can but also
there are real threats to women across
the world right now from abusive men
predatory men misogyny sexism you know
places like texas trying to reduce the
right to abortion let's focus on the
real threats to women's safety rather
than
things that might be perceived threats
but in reality in my view or not right
first minister much appreciated thank
you very much